that is what it looks like it literally
looks wow this is when my hormonal rage
how do you feel good rock this sauce for
my pregnancy diet what is right what is
wrong what are we even supposed to eat I
don't know I'm Hannah I'm the world's
okay it's mom and as many of you have
probably noticed I don't pay that much
attention to my diet but I'm super
pregnant so for the past week my family
and I have tried out three pregnancy
meal plans from three different sources
to crack the case of what actually works
and here's what happened there are so
many conversations around diet in
general and what works and what you
should do and how much protein you
should get and how many carbs you should
be having and I don't really involve
myself in any of that so for this Brown
of pregnancy I decided to pay a little
bit closer attention the rules for this
experiment are my family and I are going
to try three different pregnancy meal
plans each for one day I judged each one
based on my overall energy level my
hunger level and the convenience now
before we go into the logistics of all
of this just know that I'm not a
dietitian I work very closely with my
doctor regarding any of these decisions
I make in any of the changes to my diet
so please don't change anything about
your diet without discussing with your
doctor first we are starting a new meal
plan we're gonna try the one from my
doctor today just looking at this meal
plan makes me hungry so I'm not looking
forward to it when I read this meal plan
from the doctor for the first time it
made me laugh it reads like a diet I
would follow if I was not pregnant and
wanted to lose a lot of weight today's
breakfast they give two options so I'm
gonna give one to the boys and one for
me and Matt cuz I know
the boys really won't like one of them
for the boys we're going to do a half a
cup of cooked plain oatmeal half a cup
of blueberries one teaspoon of honey 1/2
a cup of full fat milk then for me and
Matt it's gonna be one egg and one egg
white one cup of spinach 1/2 a cup of
mushrooms 1 tomato and 1/2 a cup of full
fat milk okay
I've already done the measurements wrong
I was gonna do 2 cups of mushrooms but
it's only 1/2 a cup each so that means
like 2 mushrooms per person sliced the
portioning was so neurotic down to the
amount of leaves of lettuce you're
allowed to eat and it just it's the
complete opposite of the way I live my
life Rosie how does this smell man I do
not you muttering this is dumb ok
just look like watery eggs I feel like I
would eat this if I was trying to lose
weight which I'm not trying to lose
weight right now so that's why this
frustrates me because the boys half a
cup of oats one teaspoon of honey to
this which is really tiny and then half
a cup of blueberries oh what's this
what do you think it is blueberry it's
just normal breakfast too like it mm-hmm
okay try yours do you think that's
enough yeah
Julianne I feel like Matt was faking a
little bit through this about how fine
he was with everything because he is
always hungry and when he's hungry he's
always cranky about it but with this
breakfast he was like mmm it was great
it was just the right amount of food I
like a nice fish breakfast I'm like okay
skinny what are you talking about all
right it's good it's healthy I just wish
I could have made it my way the boys ate
it it was fine but they weren't thrilled
you don't like it gosh the drama I
wonder where he gets it okay I'm packing
lunches and save lunch one slice of
quinoa bread four ounces of Turkey one
medium tomato three leaves of lettuce
one medium carrot mustard to taste olive
oil 1/2 a cup of cottage cheese I'm not
getting quinoa bread here's my thing if
I threw in a more than one grocery store
I'm not gonna get it the lunch was
probably my least favorite part of the
meal plan because it was an open-faced
sandwich it was the sandwich with one
slice of bread which I'm not gonna pack
that in my kids lunch I'm not gonna be
like here's a one slice of bread turkey
sandwich like they're at school all day
they're running around all day and I
gave them enough food to get them
through the day
no not do you think this is enough food
yeah that's fine you don't even get a
top piece of bread I'll lose some weight
anyway Oh again Matt I think was just
grateful that the food was normal so he
was fine with it but I know he cheated
too
he didn't tell me what I'll see ate but
I know he ain't more than that for lunch
I am already hungry I think I will eat
one of my six to eight almonds I don't
eat them too fast
I immediately cheated and I ate chips
I'm not even sorry back on track today
and we're making dinner which is half a
cup of cooked quinoa pasta half a cup of
marinara sauce four ounces of ground
beef three small Brussels sprouts one
Belgian aandhi and one ounce of cheese
so I'm gonna go ahead and mix the on DB
coz I'm not going to use those I'm not
gonna buy a whole thing just to use one
for each person because that seems very
wasteful again what the portioning I
would like to better understand why this
meal plan was written out in this way
because the strict portioning seems
really restrictive to me so much so
kindly prepped the pasta we did find
quinoa pasta I called out a win and then
we're just gonna divvy out the sauce
accordingly to everybody how do you feel
I feel good I rock this sauce right here
but I feel like you're the one having
the easiest time with all this I'm so
hungry and cranky okay time to plate
this is a half a cup of pasta a half a
cup of sauce three full Brussels sprout
- cheese dinner dinner in my house is
when everyone kind of goes to town which
might not be the best diet wise but
that's just what we do
everyone gets seconds for the most part
people enjoy themselves during dinner at
my house question you can only have
three small ones so take take your time
oh wow
you're going really fast you're gonna
regret that what do you think everybody
ended up cheating what's that oh that
doesn't look like half a cup oh my
goodness the only one for usual who is
not finished is Wyatt because I don't
know how crazy he is about the meal
right honey you liked it yeah
he liked the Brussels sprouts too after
eating the doctor-recommended meal plan
my overall energy was fine because I
cheated my overall hunger level was fine
because I cheated in terms of
convenience it was moderately convenient
some of the ingredients were tough to
source like quinoa pasta or quinoa bread
that's kind of a specialty grocery run
but overall the meals were pretty easy
to cook
I just don't think food can be treated
in a one-size-fits-all way like that and
also there were no treats like where's
the treat menu come on okay it is time
for a retro pregnancy meal plan and this
is where things get weird when we went
really far back the foods were just not
anything that anyone should be eating
right now especially while pregnant so
we got a little more recent and chosen
meal
playing from the 40s from start with our
breakfast medicinal iron 2 teaspoons of
cod liver oil 2 tablespoons of wheat
germ 1 orange 1 egg and 1 half of all
cereals and grains need to be
whole-grain so I think I have an idea of
what I'm gonna make for breakfast I like
that there are some options here and
it's not so strict are you excited yeah
do you even know what we're gonna eat no
get ready there were a couple added
elements of foods I've never really had
one of which was wheat germ and one of
which was cod liver oil capsules here
are the cod liver oil capsules the iron
pill and my prenatals do you think
you're getting something do you think
you're getting something now looking at
the ingredients and the vitamin
properties of these it actually seems
pretty progressive that these would be
on meal plans from the 1940s because
they have a lot of really good qualities
but I didn't know specifically how to
prepare the wheat germ I have this
cereal and I'm just gonna sprinkle some
wheat germ
on it so overall breakfast looks like a
lot of food
oh and he's just kidding who's starting
the thing that I really liked about the
breakfast was there was a balance of
carbs and protein it wasn't just protein
or just carbs and so it felt like a much
fuller breakfast I put the full two
tablespoons of wheat germ in my oatmeal
it has a very distinct flavor of baby
formula hmm what does it taste like to
you how does it make you feel no I'm
still trying to figure it out it's like
baby formula okay it's not the best I
mean baby formula doesn't taste good
there's no good way to have a baby
formula flavor time to make lunch
very strange meal plan I'm gonna be
honest an average serving of butter and
meat two servings of vegetables in
addition to a potato so I'm going to
make turkey patties and asparagus
roasted asparagus and I will put some
butter on the asparagus and again half
of the cereals and grains consumed need
to be whole grain so that means we can
actually eat some chips hey I opted to
make turkey burgers for lunch because
the meal plan didn't specify what kind
of meat I was supposed to make and I
knew that turkey burgers were something
my family would eat looks good looks
like a nice complete meal the veggies
were good I loved that it just said two
servings of veggies not you know three
sticks of asparagus or something like
that so we were each able to have full
servings of the sides that we wanted
with our lunch as well good
yeah I actually feel good from breakfast
and lunch today so I'm gonna work out I
was feeling it until we had dinner so
what we have left to eat is the potato
maybe some more grains and the other
thing that this meal plan recommends is
liver once a week now I don't think I've
ever eaten liver we are not a huge
meat-eating household so this to me is
going to be the hardest thing for us
tough to do
gosh why couldn't it be a rack of ribs
I've consulted a couple people who have
made it before it looks like I'm going
to have to rinse it and soak it in milk
for a couple hours to get rid of the
bitterness and the smell but knowing
that my sense of smell is very sensitive
right now I don't know how well I'm
gonna do preparing this liver I have a
feeling I'm going to cry because I
already feel like I'm going to cry for
the cows whose livers I have but I took
off on my jewelry you gonna have to
touch this alright
oh my god oh okay I need some like
essential oil okay as oil in my nose the
biggest hurdle for me was the texture of
the raw liver
it's very slimy it feels almost like a
heart or something oh god oh dear Lord
and it's just very glistening like
gloppy bloody Oh God slimy smells not my
favorite all right it's time to start
cooking this I've been putting it off
long enough I'm preheating the oven to
make baked potatoes which should be
interesting because neither one of my
kids likes potatoes all right
liver is frying up it actually doesn't
smell bad smells okay just looks odd so
the kids didn't even ask what it was
they just dug in and after a few seconds
you could see their face turn from happy
to confused
he's like nothing what happened honey
the aftertaste is bad yeah I think it
was the texture that threw the moth and
the underlying flavors so they ended up
not liking it it's an odd texture it
kind of is like the flavor is that like
nothing I've had before but now I've had
it and I did it and I followed the diet
I'm proud of myself so now we can have
our baked potatoes yeah yeah overall for
the 1940s meal plan my energy level was
high my hunger level was low and in
terms of convenience it was terrible I
never want to cook liver again that was
such an ordeal Oh
the third and final meal plan was a meal
delivery service for pregnant people
it's called 25/8 I did not know that
these existed it definitely didn't exist
when I was pregnant with my other two
and what a time to be alive yeah oh my
gosh it looks incredible this meal plan
is customizable based on dietary needs
and restrictions and you can choose how
many days you'd like to have it
okay this morning's breakfast is going
to be this flourless seed bread toasted
and assess meat breakfast bowl with
broccoli and ginger lentils and I'm
gonna be honest I already tried some of
this because it looked so good it's
black sesame milk and just
thing ever breakfast was a meal that I
was especially excited about because it
is right up my alley in terms of all the
foods I love it's all something that I
would eat for breakfast if I had the
time to make it which I you don't so I'm
really excited I get to eat this for
breakfast today
hojae's how about the bread good mmm
it's really good
it's very hearty like there's a lot of
food in each bowl and I know I'm gonna
be very full after this the second I
took one look at it I knew that why it
would be pissed
he's over here hiding okay you know try
and do the broccoli one taste which
gonna do this or are you the one with
the long neck or the one with the short
neck short neck then you can't reach
let's see you try
oh I don't think you can you're next too
short see too short too short
oh you got it good job for those of you
out there with picky eaters uh maybe
give the dinosaur neck trick a try see
how it works
the only thing that works for us lunch
time
I'm packing lunches for me and Matt
we're going to do the oven-baked Dijon
salmon burger and fall veggie hash for
the boys they're gonna do egg roll in a
bowl looks delicious boys love Chinese
food so I think that's gonna be good
this looks delicious these salmon cakes
look really good and then for snacks we
have collagen almond butter bites and
how do you know what this is but rose
petal buttercup bites silence
my lunch say you help try my sandwich
makes sound interesting I probably
should have thought about bringing
salmon to work to microwave I was that
person that day honestly I was pretty
full from breakfast I wasn't left hungry
at all so I probably won't even finish
this that's a lot of food and it's
really filling it's really good
how'd you like your lunch today it was
good when everybody got home we were
very hungry and so we had an afternoon
snack which was part of the meal plan
which was excellent
he's our pumpkin spice muffins
what do you think
and your brother in to have one who are
you how do you think that movement
[Music]
perfect after-school snack huh yeah
that's delicious this food makes you
dance yeah look at how much my movie
made you dance like okay I'm fooling my
PJs I figured I should actually give you
guys a little bump date does I don't
know if I've really showed it that much
here it is it's getting there it's
really big at the end of the day let me
tell you it gets very swollen and on
that note I will show you what I'm going
to fill it up with to make it even
bigger tonight's dinner is a
pasture-raised chicken bootable with
veggies and quinoa and it looks
delicious and so I'm gonna whip these up
for each of us and I whip them up I mean
put them on the plate and see how the
kids do you know I took one look at it
and I knew I would love it Matt would
love it Jackson would love it why it
would hate it what do you see I'm
actually really proud of how open-minded
why it was with this meal plan usually
he refuses to try anything new or
anything that's outside of his little
wheel of foods he will eat and he gave
everything a try so he tasted the bowl
didn't love it ate a little bit of the
chicken but the big deal was he tried it
[Music]
mmm it was it fed she's our really good
start like chickpeas and pumpkin seeds
in here mmm but super filling I can tell
already I think this one is probably my
favorite I don't know the breakfast was
really good so it's hard to pick overall
for the meal delivery service energy
level was high hunger level was low and
convenience was a pregnant woman's dream
all energy was heat things up and like
put him in a bowl it was beautiful
it was ah so easy with a meal plan like
this you are paying for the convenience
though so it's just something to keep in
mind it comes at a price
but it is very very convenient so how
did we fare overall between these three
meal plans well my absolute favorite was
the meal delivery service I feel like it
was healthy without being limiting it
didn't limit portions it didn't restrict
my intake of food and it was very
thoughtful towards you know having a bit
of a sweet tooth when you're pregnant
for me that was my absolute favorite
meal plan and I would love to eat it
forever even though their opinion is
secondary because these meal plans are
for pregnant people all three boys
favorite meal plan was the 1940s meal
plan something about men and their meat
I don't know what it is so that's like
up for today I'm Hannah and if you liked
any of those meal plans let me know in
the comments I want to hear what you
would eat from those or if you have a
better way of cooking liver please leave
that in the comments as well I feel
please excuse me I have some treats to
eat to make up for all the lost time I
had with them until next time yes I'm in
the bathroom but this is how I don't
have to share with my kids
[Music]
returning to my home